okay let's take a question from joe
hey jason my name is joe selvik and i am
a co-founder of fixturefab.com
we provide pcba test fixture solutions
that makes testing hardware
easier my question for you is based on
the re-shoring of manufacturing to the
united states
and i would like to know where you see
the greatest opportunity for startups to
have a role in this
okay this is a great question we have
some concerns
uh here in america after coronavirus
that
certain things in the supply chain we
were unable to get and that we don't
make them here in america anymore
typically uh on the short list um ppe
um and drugs like
pharmaceutical drugs uh and those are
all made in china
and we have a dependency there right and
so we found out oh
wow when uh there's a pandemic we might
not
have the stuff that we need so we could
stockpile or we could start making stuff
here
and there's a bigger issue which is do
we want to have our country be dependent
on an authoritarian communist country
i.e
china or any of the countries that we've
been dependent on
that are authoritarian we had the same
issue with oil previously
uh with saudi arabia and the in the in
the middle east
and when we became energy independent
and when
solar and natural gas and fracking and
all this technology came out
boy did that change our relationship
with the middle east and most people
would argue for the better
we're no longer dependent they don't
have the upper hand with us
but when it comes to the relationship
with china we they do have the upper
hand now i
the the rub here is that a startup
trying to address this um
it's an opportunity but you're at risk
of if this trend actually emerges where
more people build stuff in the united
states so
i think you're going to have to study
which things are going to be made here
in the united states
and you're going to have to just meet
with those people and you know
take it month by month quarter by
quarter because
there is a chance that coronavirus
passes people forget that this is an
issue and we go
right back to being dependent on china
uh
and uh it's not a xenophobic thing this
is a supply chain issue
if we become really good at supply chain
which we did
we will have just a very small amount of
inventory now in a way that's super
efficient
it's a great thing because you don't
have wasted inventory you don't have to
throw things away
you make things just in time and
actually tim cook and apple was really
good at managing that supply chain
but when things go wrong oh boy you
don't want to be in a position where
all the prescription drugs that you need
or some large percentage of them
are only made in china or when we need
masks and ventilators we're unable to
build that stuff
now you saw over let's call it three to
six months we've been able to
ramp up that production but i think it's
a bright future i would think about it
in a very holistically
holistic way and i would be part of that
movement of manufacturing the united
states
one way for you to be part of that
change is to start a podcast or a blog
and a social media account or all three
of those things around
uh this topic and trying to build
some consensus around who's doing this
so if you make the content you start
interviewing people on your podcast or
you write blog posts about it
or you just tweet about it all day long
and engage people and make lists of
people
who are in manufacturing the united
states you can become the center
center of attention for that discussion
which is what i did for startups right
when i had my magazines when i have this
podcast itself that you're listening to
right
now when i host events like launch fest
or founder university i've become a
center
right a super router we would call it in
the industry
which means i get to not have to do the
research of what great companies are
coming they
basically come to us right and that's
what you could be if you become that
center hub
of uh the content and the discussion
well
people might come to you with the
opportunity so good luck with it i think
it's important work